Celebrar unos Juegos Olímpicos en plena
pandemia es como el final de Juego de
Tronos. Hay algo que no termina de encajar.
Se supone que es la gran fiesta del deporte
y luego te encuentras las gradas vacías.
Ya pasó el verano pasado en Tokyo y está
pasando ahora con los Juegos Olímpicos de
Invierno que se están celebrando en China.
Los deportes de invierno, desde luego,
no levantan grandes pasiones salvo que,
claro, seas de Noruega, de Canadá o de
cualquier otro lugar más apropiado para
los osos polares que para la vida humana.
La cuestión, amigos, es que si Beijing 2022
provoca grandes titulares va a ser por cualquier
cosa menos por la lucha por las medallas. El
régimen de Xi Jinping ha intentado reeditar
el éxito de los Juegos de 2008. De hecho la
propaganda china no ha parado de destacar
que Beijing es la primera ciudad que organiza
los Juegos Olímpicos de Verano y de Invierno.
Y es verdad: todos recordamos Beijing
2008 como el momento en el que el gigante
asiático despertó y se presentó al mundo
como una gran superpotencia económica.
El Estadio del Nido de Pájaro se convirtió en un
icono de la nueva y moderna China. Todo un éxito
de imagen que además fue acompañado del éxito
deportivo por los anfitriones. China ganó más
medallas de oro que nunca y por primera vez en
la Historia lideró el medallero. Pero amigos,
mucho han cambiado las cosas desde 2008.
(La Administración Biden no enviará ninguna
representación diplomática u oficial a
los Juegos Olímpicos y Paralímpicos de
Invierno de Beijing 2022 dado el genocidio en
curso y los crímenes contra la humanidad de la
República Popular China en Xinjiang y otros abusos
contra los derechos humanos. Jen Psaki, secretaria
de Prensa de la Casa Blanca.)
El boicot anunciado por el Gobierno
de Estados Unidos ha sido secundado por
Australia, Canadá, Reino Unido y Nueva
Zelanda. También se sumaron Japón, Alemania,
Dinamarca y Países Bajos. Hay que aclarar que
este boicot es solo diplomático y que en ningún
caso ha supuesto la retirada de sus deportistas.
Pero lo más importante es que en el último año
son muchos los países que ya han alzado la voz.
Denuncian los abusos de los derechos humanos
que China está cometiendo sobre los uigures,
la represión en Hong Kong y la presión
que está ejerciendo sobre Taiwán.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Cómo se ha tomado China
este boicot diplomático a Beijing 2022? ¿Qué
podemos esperar de estos Juegos Olímpicos? Y lo
que es más importante ¿Cómo piensa aprovechar
los Juegos el régimen comunista de Xi Jinping?
Hoy vamos a responder a estas preguntas pero,
antes de continuar, vamos a hacer otra pregunta
¿Cómo invierten su dinero los españoles? Sí,
vale, seguramente nunca os hayáis
hecho esta pregunta pero… ¿De verdad
los españoles sacamos el máximo partido a
nuestros ahorros? ¡Tranquilos! Esto no es
un anuncio en el que os voy a decir cómo
haceros ricos. Esto es el tema del último
vídeo de “Si lo Hubiera Sabido”. Un vídeo en
el que explicamos cuales son las principales
tendencias de inversión en España ¿Qué
hacemos bien los españoles? ¿Qué hacemos
mal? Ya sabéis que “Si lo Hubiera Sabido” es
el canal de Mutuactivos en el que colabora
VisualPolitik donde hablamos de finanzas. Todo
ello con rigor, investigación y sin el clásico
clickbait. Os dejo el enlace en la descripción.
Y ahora sí, vamos a ver un poco de historia.
(UNA MEDIDA SIMBÓLICA)
Los boicots en los grandes eventos deportivos
son como las referencias sexuales baratas en
una canción de reggaeton. No pueden faltar
nunca. El objetivo suele ser presionar al
país boicoteado a introducir algunos cambios.
Como podéis imaginar, sirven más bien para
poco. Pero ahí quedan los titulares. Desde
luego, si los hicieran Orban, Bolsonaro o
Maduro diríamos que son un gesto populista.
Ahora, no hay nada más populista que amenazar
con hacer un boicot y luego no llevarlo a cabo
sin que entre medias haya cambiado nada. Eso es
lo que pasó con los Juegos Olímpicos de Berlín en
1936. Muchos países amenazaron con no participar
como medida de protesta contra el régimen nazi.
Y resulta que al final participaron 49 países,
más que nunca hasta entonces. Menos mal que
luego Jesse Owens nos dio varias satisfacciones.
Después vendría la Guerra Fría y el que
sería el padre de todos los boicots: en 1980,
Estados Unidos y otros 60 países optaron por
no ir a los Juegos Olímpicos de Moscú. Esto
era una protesta contra la invasión soviética
de Afganistán. 4 años después fue el turno de
la Unión Soviética, que junto con otros países
del bloque del Este, boicotearon los juegos
de Los Ángeles de 1984 ¿Sirvieron para algo
estos boicots? Obviamente no ¡Pero esperad un
momento porque sí hay un boicot que tuvo efecto!
Sudáfrica tuvo prohibida la participación en los
grandes eventos deportivos entre 1964 y 1992 como
protesta por el apartheid. Podríamos decir que
este fue el boicot más exitoso. Tal vez el único
que realmente ha tenido un efecto político real.
El problema es que este tipo de boicot no es
algo que se vaya a repetir contra un gigante
como China. Estamos hablando del país más poblado
del mundo y eso se traduce en que es uno de los
mercados más importantes para el Comité Olímpico
Internacional. Hay demasiados intereses en juego.
También estadounidenses. Porque aparte de los
deportistas que se quedaron sin competir en
Moscú 1980, el mayor perjudicado de aquel boicot
fue la NBC. La televisión que se había hecho con
los derechos para retransmitir los Juegos en
Estados Unidos perdió 22 millones de dólares.
Por eso es impensable este boicot contra los
Juegos de Beijing vaya más allá de la diplomacia.
El Gobierno de Xi Jinping ha tratado de restarle
importancia asegurando que los representantes de
Estados Unidos no pueden renunciar a ir a
una fiesta a la que no han sido invitados.
Esta ha sido la respuesta más educada. Luego está
Zhao Lijian, uno de los portavoces del Ministerio
chino de Asuntos Exteriores, que cree que lo
mejor que puede hacer China para justificar
lo que sucede en Xinjiang es pasar al ataque.
(Estados Unidos se construyó sobre el saqueo
de la patria de los indios nativos
y los crímenes contra la humanidad.
¿Qué autoridad tiene para difamar las políticas
étnicas de otros países basándose en mentiras
y desinformación? ¿Cuál es la agenda oculta
detrás de todos sus rumores y difamaciones?)
Como estáis viendo, esto no va más allá
del típico cruce de declaraciones entre
los Gobiernos de dos países rivales. Al final
el boicot diplomático se quedará en una medida
más o menos simbólica. Al unirse otros países,
mayor será el efecto negativo sobre la imagen
de China. Pero tampoco podemos engañarnos
y hacernos ilusiones. En primer lugar,
nada va a cambiar dentro del gigante asiático
por un boicot así. Y luego, sobre todo,
estamos de nuevo ante unos Juegos Olímpicos
en plena pandemia. La atención de los medios
pronto se desviará a otros asuntos.
Y os preguntaréis: entonces ¿Por qué
le dedicamos un vídeo en VisualPolitik a
este tema? Pues ahora mismo lo vamos a ver.
(MUCHOS YUANES Y POCA NIEVE)
Beijing fue designada como sede de
estos Juegos en julio de 2015. Por aquel entonces
Donald Trump solo había sido presidente de Estados
Unidos en los Simpson y Occidente no mostraba
aún tanta desconfianza hacia China. Sin embargo,
la situación ha cambiado mucho hoy en día.
China cada vez genera más desconfianza en todo
el mundo. Y los Juegos Olímpicos también.
Para que os hagáis una idea, Oslo retiró
su candidatura para estos juegos después de ver
todos los sobrecostos de los juegos olímpicos de
Sochi 2014. De hecho, la otra candidatura
que competía con Beijing para estos juegos
era Almaty (((SUSURRANDO))) Para quien no
lo sepa, Almaty es la capital de Kazajistán.
Y diréis ¿Cuáles son los requisitos que pone el
Comité Olímpico Internacional para que una
ciudad tenga Juegos Olímpicos de invierno?
Alguno pensará… que algo fundamental es que la
ciudad anfitriona tenga nieve
¿Verdad? Pues… nada de eso.
(Casi toda la nieve en los Juegos Olímpicos
de Invierno de Beijing será falsa)
Tal cual como lo escucháis, los Juegos
Olímpicos de Invierno se celebran en un
lugar donde nieva menos que en Londres. El
clima en Beijing es seco: casi desértico.
Así que han tenido que construir un
sistema de transferencia de agua que
necesita más de 223 millones de litros
de agua. Eso es lo que hace falta para
alimentar todos los cientos de cañones de nieve.
Y diréis ¿A qué viene este disparate tan poco
sostenible? Pues básicamente obedece a
dos claves. La primera es la PROPAGANDA.
La principal virtud de las sedes olímpicas de
Zhangjiakou y de Yangqing es que se encuentran
a 200 y a 100 kilómetros de Beijing. A eso hay
que sumarle que algunos recintos utilizados en
los Juegos de 2008 han sido readaptados. El
Water Cube que acogió la natación ahora es
el Ice Cube para los partidos de curling. El
estadio del balonmano y la gimnasia ahora es
la sede del hockey hielo. Y el Nido de Pájaro
acogerá las ceremonias de apertura y de clausura.
Todo esto para presumir de que Beijing
es la primera ciudad en acoger los Juegos
Olímpicos de Verano y de Invierno. Esto nos
conecta directamente con la segunda clave. Al
estar las sedes tan dispersas, China se ha gastado
más de 9.000 millones de dólares en construir un
tren de alta velocidad que une Beijing con las
estaciones de esquí cercanas a Zhangjiakou y
Yangqing. Desde luego parece un enorme derroche
de yuanes ya que el esquí no es un deporte muy
popular en China. Pero el régimen quiere impulsar
el desarrollo del esquí cerca de Beijing para
dar servicio a su clase media acomodada.
En China practicar el esquí es sinónimo de
una buena posición social. Seguro que os parece
un objetivo tan clasista socialmente que creéis
que os estoy hablando del siglo pasado.
Pero en China las cosas funcionan así.
Y, como os podéis imaginar, todo el interés
de Beijing es que estos juegos sean una obra
maestra de la propaganda. Y están
cuidando hasta el último detalle.
(China advierte a los atletas
olímpicos extranjeros que no
hablen sobre política en los Juegos de Invierno)
El hecho de que no haya público hará mucho más
sencillo para el régimen comunista controlar
cualquier tipo de protesta. De hecho llama
mucho la atención que mientras en Occidente ya
han vuelto los eventos deportivos con público,
en China el Gobierno se ha mantenido firme
en prohibir la asistencia de espectadores a
los Juegos. Tampoco debe extrañarnos porque es
bastante coherente con el cierre estricto de
fronteras que viene aplicando durante la pandemia.
Sea como sea, os aseguro que en estos momentos la
principal preocupación de Xi Jinping es
otra. ¿De qué estamos hablando? Atentos.
(EL ÚLTIMO FRACASO DE XI JINPING)
2022 es un año importante para Xi Jinping. En
teoría debería ser el momento de su despedida.
Así pasó con Jiang Zemin y Hu Jintao, que dejaron
sus cargos al cumplir 10 años en el poder. Sin
embargo, mis queridos amigos de VisualPolitik,
esta vez será diferente. Todo indica que el
Congreso del Partido Comunista declarará el
próximo otoño a Xi Jinping como presidente de
China hasta… bueno, pues hasta que este señor
se canse de mandar. Al más puro estilo Mao.
Por este motivo Xi Jinping quiere que la
organización de estos Juegos alcance la
perfección. Quiere que el país vuelva a recibir
los mismos elogios que cosechó con Beijing 2008.
Desde luego, al igual que cuando organizó aquellos
Juegos Olímpicos, China no ha reparado en gastos.
En aquel momento, hace 14 años, sorprendieron al
mundo y mostraron un gran mercado para todo aquel
dispuesto a aprovecharlo. Pero el panorama
mundial ha cambiado mucho desde entonces.
A principios de siglo se creía en Occidente
que dialogar con China favorecería una mayor
liberalización y apertura del régimen comunista.
Ahora ya no. Desde que Xi Jinping llegó al poder
en 2012, China se ha convertido en un Estado
cada vez más autoritario. Frente al perfil
discreto de Hu Jintao, Xi Jinping ha desplegado
una política exterior agresiva. Y claro, el choque
con Occidente ha sido inevitable, sobre todo
desde que Trump puso sus pies en la Casa Blanca.
Así que el principal problema de Xi Jinping no es
que Beijing 2022 vaya a ser una ruina económica,
porque unos yuanes arriba o abajo está claro que
es la menor de sus preocupaciones. Su principal
problema es que los Juegos van a ser también un
fracaso a nivel de propaganda. Porque la mayor
parte del planeta ya ve a China con otros ojos.
Primero fue la guerra comercial de Donald Trump.
Después la toma del poder en Hong Kong, las
tensiones con Taiwan y, finalmente el Coronavirus.
China no solo obstaculizó las
investigaciones sobre el origen
del covid-19 sino que además ha atacado a
Australia por pedir una mayor transparencia.
Si recordáis, durante todo 2020 China quiso
seducir al mundo con lo que llamábamos la
diplomacia de las mascarillas… con resultados
dudosos. En 2021, China quiso repetir la operación
esta vez con la diplomacia de la vacuna. Y
en este caso, el fracaso fue sonado. Atentos.
(El aumento de los contagios de COVID-19
en algunos países que usaron vacunas chinas
genera dudas sobre su eficacia. NY Times)
Las vacunas chinas fueron de las primeras
en salir. Pero luego han demostrado
tener una eficacia bastante reducida
en comparación con otras opciones. Esto
ha perjudicado considerablemente la imagen
de China en muchos países. Sus empresas
han perdido credibilidad en el exterior.
Pero esperad un momento, porque dentro
de China tampoco están mucho mejor.
Evergrande, una de las principales empresas
del país, está en suspensión de pagos y al
borde de la quiebra. Sus problemas de liquidez
han sacudido los cimientos de la economía china.
Y por si estos problemas fueran pocos,
Xi Jinping ha visto como en septiembre
se formalizaba la AUKUS, una alianza
estratégica militar entre Estados Unidos,
Reino Unido y Australia que tiene como objetivo
plantar cara a los intereses chinos en la región
del Indo-Pacífico. Por todo ello estos Juegos
Olímpicos llegan en un momento muy delicado
para Xi Jinping. Los Juegos de Beijing
2008 fueron la puesta de gala de China.
Estos juegos de 2022 pueden convertirse en
el símbolo de la caída en desgracia de China.
Así que la pregunta es ¿Creéis que la presión
internacional sobre China puede provocar algún
cambio en el gigante asiático? ¿O pensáis
que hubiera sido mejor un boicot total sobre
los Juegos para no ser cómplices del régimen
comunista? Podéis dejarme vuestra respuesta en
los comentarios. Y, por supuesto, no olvidéis
que sacamos vídeos nuevos todas las semanas.
Así que suscribíos al canal para no perderos
ninguna de nuestras actualizaciones. Si os ha
gustado este vídeo, dadle a LIKE y nos vemos
en el próximo. ¡Un abrazo y hasta pronto!